this nation is called the United States
of America and doesn't like many other
countries its name was deliberately
chosen France for example comes from the
Latin word Frankie a land of the Franks
but it wasn't chosen by a committee of
Frenchmen it simply stuck over the
centuries the question is who named the
United States why was that name selected
and what were the alternatives so prior
to the American Revolution these lands
were known to the British as British
North America or simply the colonies and
the officials that lived there often
used the name the United colonies of
North America the name America in case
you're wondering had been a commonly
used term for a couple of centuries by
this point and was derived from America
Vespucci an early Explorer this along
with the rare a Columbia named for
Christopher Columbus was used to
describe the entire land mass there were
not just the British colonies there when
tension started to rise people began to
use different terms to describe the 13
colonies when the American Revolution
broke out it was Thomas Jefferson who
first used the term United States of
America and its use was formalized by
John Hancock and the Continental
Congress in late 1776 colloquially
United States in American states were
frequently used by citizens and it's one
of the reasons why the name took hold
this didn't mean that the name was fixed
though when dealing with the French
Benjamin Franklin used the term United
States of North America and when peace
was made with the British they did so
under the name the United States so that
settled them right well no there were
some in the new USA that didn't like the
name and wish to change it to something
less descriptive and more poetic
the number one alternative proposed was
Columbia and whilst this was the most
popular alternative many was simply used
to calling the country the United States
by now and so felt that there was no
need to change anything by the time that
the US Constitution was drafted the
United States was kept as the nation's
name or more specifically the
alternatives weren't properly discussed
in 1819 though the opportunity was lost
forever since another country took the
name Columbia but by this point another
contender had arrived and that name was
Fredonia which was derived from the word
freedom and made to sound a little bit
Latin II to give it some weight and the
man who coined this name was Samuel
Arthur Mitchell Mitchell felt that the
name United States was a boring one that
didn't promote an idea of national
identity since no one was going to call
themselves United States ian's whereas
people from Fredonia could called
themselves Fredonia pne's Fried's or the
free dish now Fredonia gained some
traction with
the senators who supported the renaming
of the nation however Mitchell's new
name stood before it could get anywhere
because it became a term of mockery for
the overly patriotic and it was with
this that the last alternative to United
States died forever and in the end the
name for the United States was chosen in
haste it's simply being a change from
the United colonies that the people who
lived there had known him as that their
entire lives and its position was
solidified by early diplomatic use
whilst alternatives to United States
such as Colombia and Fredonia were
discussed the old name had stuck and
there was no real desire to change it
especially after Colombia was taken the
United States wasn't the poetic name
that many had wanted but it was
ultimately the most reflective at the
country's birth and after the Civil War
it took on a much greater weight than
anyone had anticipated I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching but thanks to my patreon
supporters whom you can see on screen
now and with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette Ike Danny Maloney
calling Castleman Marvin Castle Rob
Waterhouse Aaron the white Jordan long
way Chris wicker Gustav Swann Gareth
Turner
Marcus Ozma Maggie packs Kowski David
Silverman spinning three plates
Spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Winston
k-word Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell par shoe 19 and Moe